quittons les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
donc monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues alors nous entendons donc cet
après-midi Monsieur Pierre Moscovici
premier Président et Madame Véronique à
maillon président de la 6e chambre de la
Cour des comptes
dont c'est la première édition en cette
qualité devant notre commission pour la
présentation du rapport annuel sur
l'application
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale autrement dit le Ralph
son compagnie de Stéphane sellier
rapporteur général du ralphes Thibault
Perrin rapporteur général adjoint Guy
Guillaume de la battue chargé de mission
et Romain bauffret chargé mission près
du premier président j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo en vue de sa retransmission en
direct sur le site du Sénat elle sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande
chaque année appareille époque la
présentation du rapport sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale qui constitue l'une
des traductions de la mission
d'assistance de la cour au Parlement
prévu par l'article 47-2 de la
Constitution ouvre pour notre commission
les travaux sur le PLFSS de l'année à
venir en application de la loi organique
du 14 mars 2022 cet exercice est
désormais postérieur à la présentation
du PLFSS en conseil des ministres et en
modifie quelque peu la nature en
application de ce même texte nous aurons
d'ailleurs à examiner une loi
d'approbation des comptes sociaux à
l'été qui nous conduira avancer le
regard rétrospectif porté sur l'exercice
clos et à solliciter une nouvelle fois
la cour à l'automne pour un regard plus
prospectif
je note que cette année les insertions
rapports sont nombreuses à pouvoir être
relié à un article Lutex comme celui sur
les négociations conventionnelles et j'y
vois matière à inspiration pour les
sénateurs monsieur le Premier Président
je vous laisse la parole
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci de m'avoir invité à vous présenter
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur la
sécurité sociale c'est avec grand
plaisir que je retrouve votre commission
pour cet exercice annuel important je
m'écoutais comme vous l'avez dit
Véronica maillon de nouvelles présidents
de la sixième chambre Stéphane sellier
conseiller maître qui est le rapporteur
général de ce rapport Thibault Perrin a
partagéa adjoint je voudrais devant vous
mentionner aussi évidemment ce que vous
connaissez c'est le rôle majeur de Denis
Morin qui était Président jusqu'à il y a
très peu de la sixième chambre dans la
conception de ce rapport important que
je souhaite remercier tous ceux qui ont
œuvré son élaboration c'est des
suggésité plus une vingtaine d'autres
rapporteurs qui ont contribué à ce
travail lourd approfondi que je crois
utile le rapport que je vais vous
présenter mettez des bicônes chaque
année dans le cadre de la mission
consuel d'assistance de la cour au
Parlement et au gouvernement il
accompagne les projets de financement la
sécurité sociale 2023 vous avez rappelé
qu'en effet les choses vont changer le
calendrier donc nous sommes dans cette
situation transitoire où nous vous
présentons un rapport tout on a
élaborant déjà le prochain qui pour les
équipes n'est pas simple j'ai présenté
ce travail très attendu citoyen comme
des parlementaires à la presse hier à la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'autre assemblée ce matin parce que
éclairer les parlementaires avant le
vote d'un texte financier majeur pour
notre pays c'est un une dévocation de la
cour qui fait partie de sa mission
constitutionnelle d'informations des
citoyens et j'y tiens énormément non
seulement parce que je conserve une
sensibilité dans l'âme d'anciens
parlementaires mais aussi parce que
cette un cycle qu'on soit mon rôle et
mon devoir de Premier président de la
Cour des comptes ce rapport intervient
c'était dans un contexte que vous
connaissez tension économique avec leurs
conséquences notamment sur l'inflation
mais aussi sur la croissance à venir
nécessiter d'adapter notre société tout
entière ou dérèglement climatique lutte
contre la pandémie de covid-19 qui a
continué à peser sur les dépenses
d'assurance maladie en 2021 à 2022 tout
ça laisse une empreinte durable et loin
d'être finie sur la dette et sur les
déficit public comme chacun le sait et
vous les premiers les transferts sociaux
je dois payer un rôle essentiel ils
viennent de le prouver en amortissant
mais il y a plutôt efficace les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire et
nous sommes tous ici d'accord sur le
fait que la protection sociale est un
pilier de la République mais pour être
efficace demain comme l'été hier elle
doit être solide elle va s'installer
durablement dans l'accumulation non
maîtrisée de déficit la dette
d'aujourd'hui c'est un poids pour les
générations futures de demain et notre
devoir justement et de les en préserver
et préserver aussi une capacité à
investir dans des politiques publiques
intelligentes le rapport qui vous est
présenté montre clairement qui n'est pas
possible de différer plus longuement
de réforme de la Sécurité Sociale a
besoin travail de longue haleine qui
doit toujours être conduit avec courage
constance dans les années qui viennent
en suivant une trajectoire de
redressement que nous souhaitons
expliciter solide j'aurai l'occasion
dans quelques instants d'évoquer les
éléments de prévision qui figurent en
annexe ou FS 2023 la cour est bien sûr
conscient de difficultés que présente le
redressement des condensation sociale
son rôle c'est d'identifier des marges
efficient dans les domaines de
l'assurance maladie ou de la retraite et
le rapport qu'elle vous présente
aujourd'hui présente à l'ensemble
d'évolutions nécessaires je note
d'ailleurs comme vous avec intérêt que
cette année le PLFSS comporte de
nombreuses propositions qui prennent
déjà acte de nos propres avis
train ce rapport la Cour va dresser le
bilan tiré de l'application quelques
réformes récentes dans une démarche de
l'évaluation et elle va aussi souligner
l'incite d'améliorer la qualité de
l'action publique et des services rendus
aux assurés sociaux tout en contribuant
à l'effort de maîtrise des dépenses
avance cela je souhaite rappeler la
situation financière actuelle de la
sécurité sociale ainsi que les
perspectives pour les prochaines années
au vu des dernières données disponibles
communiqués par la Commission des
comptes de la Sécurité sociale ainsi que
la trajectoire financière
quadriennale présentée par le
gouvernement on annexe ou pffs 2023 je
commence par 2021 donc à regarder
prospectif le déficit 2021 la sécurité
sociale s'est élevé à 24,3 milliards
d'euros il reste un niveau très élevé
précisons que la Cour a signifié par son
refus d’approuver les comptes 2021 de la
cause et de l'URSSAF que deux
saint-pinière d'euros de recettes de
prélèvement sociaux ont été à notre sens
indument rattacher l'exercice 2021 et si
elles avaient été rattachées comme ça
nous paiera pertinent je crois qu'en
réalité c'était évident
en vérité à l'exercice 2020 le déficit
tout régime de 2011 a été non pas de
24,3 milliards d'euros mais de 29,3
milliards d'euros en 2022 je note la
persistance des structurelle hors
dépenses liée à la crise sanitaire
équivalent à suite 2021 aux alentours de
6 milliards d'euros ce qui est
préoccupant la Cour souligne à nouveau
la nécessité d'un programme plus réel de
réforme dans les domaines de l'assurance
médiataire retraite qui permettent à la
sécurité sociale de revenir vite un
équilibre financier pérenne or disons-le
je me tourne maintenant vers l'avenir
une telle orientation n'apparaît pas
clairement dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
certes le PLFSS prévoit une réduction du
déficitations qui passerait de près de
18 milliards d'euros en 2022 à moins de
7 en 2023 mais je le dis d'emblée cette
réduction des déficit repose sur une
hypothèse optimiste qui est celle de la
division par 10 des dépenses
exceptionnelles d'Assurance Maladie Dieu
la crise sanitaire
du point de vue comptable du point de
vue de la logique c'est un peu étrange
et nous avons considéré que cette
estimation qui suppose notamment que les
dépenses de test covid soient divisées
par 20 par rapport à 2021 risque de très
insuffisant quand vous passez des
provisions il vaut mieux prendre en
compte des risques plutôt que de tenir
compte que d'espoir l'espoir que ce soit
vrai nous l'avons le risque que ce soit
faux il est quand même assez élevé en
réalité d'où ma conclusion que cette
optimiste voilà les chiffres sont des
mots sont assez précis la croissance des
dépensations crise sanitaires seraient
dans le pffs inférieur à hausse des prix
ce qui suppose des effets d'ajustement
important des professionnels des
établissements de santé disons que au vu
du passé c'est quand même très
volontariste et donc le déficit pourrait
s'inscrire en réalité un niveau plus
élevé que celui indépendamment même des
incertitudes sur lesquelles je vais
revenir qui entourent l'environnement
macroéconomique sur lesquels le Conseil
des finances publiques que je préside
également a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
à cela s'ajoute que le montant de 123
milliards d'euros de déficit sociaux que
la Cadès a été autorisée à prendre sera
atteint en 2023 pour continuer
d'absorber des défis de sociaux à
structure de recherche de recettes
inchangées il faudra donc prolonger sa
durée de vie au delà du terme prévu de
2033 ne nous voyons pas la face il
existe un risque réel de croissance
continue de l'endettement social qui est
d'ores et déjà qui va atteindre fin 2022
160 milliards d'euros et ceci se fait je
le redis au détriment des générations
futures pour 2024 et 2025 les annexes ou
LFSS prévoit difficile à circuler de
celle qui repartira à la hausse avant de
se tasser quelques prépa par la suite en
2026 il s'élèverait après de 12
milliards d'euros
encore faut-il souligner que ce niveau
de déficit supposerait une stabilisation
des dépenses de longs dames en termes
réelles les efforts correspondant
d'économie reste dans les documents qui
nous ont été adressés à définir qu'à
mettre en oeuvre le déficit de la
branche vieillesse et du FSV at André
cantalu près de 14 milliards d'euros
compte moins de 2 milliards d'euros en
2021 raison de la dégradation de la
situation financière des régimes de
retraite de base des salariés du secteur
privé et les fonctionnaires territoriaux
hospitaliers
cette dégradation du déficit prévision
de la civilisation sociale d'autant plus
préoccupante et j'y reviens qu'elle
repose sur des prévisions de croissance
économiques qui sont considérées comme
optimistes par le au conseil pour les
finances publiques dans son avis que
j'ai présenté à la commission des
finances de votre assemblée il y a
quelques jours sur les proches de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 2027 ça me conduit
à dire que la trajectoire prévue du
retour à l'équilibre puis de
désendettement semble peu crédible
aujourd'hui il est prioritaire de la
revoir et documenter précisément les
mesures de redressement nécessaire par
ailleurs le rapport swing aussi combien
la multiplicité les fréquentes
modifications des sources de financement
les plus financiers affectent la
compréhension des sols des branches et
du FSV la cour propose vous le savez que
les sources de financement des
différentes branches vont être clarifié
simplifiés stabiliser c'est pas un sujet
théorique mais il s'agit bien au
contraire des modalités pratiques du
redressement de la sécurité social dans
la durée si ces exigences de clarté de
rigueur de stabilité ne sont pas prises
en compte le respect des trajectoires
prévus pour les différentes branches ne
pourra pas mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs être garantis enfin une
dernière notation sur les prévisions et
les aspects financiers les dépenses de
soins de ville ont augmenté trois fois
plus vite que l'inflation entre 2010 et
2021 la Cour considère à partir de là
que les professionnels libéraux de santé
doivent contribuer davantage aux
priorités nationales de santé tout en
respectant les objectifs de dépenses qui
la trajectoire pluriannuelle du risque à
dix est orientation devrait selon nous
être au centre vous l’évoquez madame la
Présidente en filigrane des prochaines
négociations entre l'assurance maladie
les syndicats de profession libérales de
santé voilà
les barèmes du CMG sont en quant à eux
défavorable aux familles les moins
aisées qui ne sont pas réellement libres
du choix du mode de garde leurs enfants
les barèmes devraient donc être
réménagés pour permettre à ces familles
les plus modestes de recourir davantage
à l'ensemble des modes de garde possible
j'ai bien noté que le SS prévoit une
mesure qui modifie le CMG dans le sens
que nous recommandons sont toutefois
touchés à la prépa nous pensons aussi
qu'il serait opportun de faire évoluer
les deux dispositifs de manière
cohérente et concomitante qui n'est pas
le cas pour garantir une meilleure
efficacité tout en évitant un coût
supplémentaire
[Musique]
à la branche famille la deuxième réforme
examinée celle de l'automatisation du
calcul des aPL des effets au logement
calculer automatiquement les prestations
à partir de données les plus récentes
dites contemporaine relatives ont reçu
vos revenus perçus par des bénéficiaires
est une bonne idée mais l'expérience des
aides personnel au logement montre les
effets délétères des erreurs
informatiques lorsqu'elles touchent les
revenus des plus précaires nous invite
donc l'administration à anticiper ces
risques techniques dans le cas des
expérimentations prévues du principe de
solidarité à la source qui est souhaitée
par le Président de la République la
priorité pour le versement des
prestations financées par la solidarité
nationale reste à nos yeux le paiement
exact c'est à dire à qui de droit en
tant et en heure en outre
l'automatisation du versement oblige à
conduire le chantier de simplification
des bases de calcul des prestations
sociales le dernier exemple porte sur le
transfert au régime général de la
gestion de la sécurité sociale des
travailleurs indépendants du fait de la
suppression du RSI
cette opération est pour nous
globalement réussi nous pensons que
l'administration doit dans une phase
ultérieure s'attacher maintenant à
pousser les réformes au-delà des
organisations de la gestion pour traiter
les problèmes de fond qui subsistent en
matière de protection sociale de ces
catégories professionnelles importantes
pour les communes de notre pays il
s'agit notamment de l'équité du
prélèvement social à la charge des
travailleurs indépendants par rapport à
celui des salariés de l'équité de ce
prélèvement entre différentes catégories
d'indépendants et de la complétude de la
protection sociale de ces derniers j'en
arrive maintenant au terme de cette
présentation rapide mon troisième et
dernier point l'amélioration et la
qualité de la qualité de la maîtrise de
la dépense dans le champ de la
protection sociale
à l'autre sens bien sûr c'est d'abord
indispensable on ne peut pas réduire les
déficits et la dette sans maîtriser la
dépense sans agir sur sa quantité mais
d'abord sur sa qualité c'est à dire ça
va prioriser des dépenses qu'il faut
éventuellement augmenter et il y en a
dans cette salle même j'étais plus
présenter un rapport sur les EHPAD où
j'avais proposé une augmentation
conséquente de l'ordre de 1,3,9
milliards d'euros des dépenses pour les
EHPAD nous y revenons d'ailleurs donc il
s'agit pas d'avoir je ne sais quel
principe de socialité générale mais il y
en a d'autres où on doit pouvoir faire
jouer pleinement les principes
d'efficacité déficience et faire mais
oui des économies sans dégrader et
parfois même en améliorant la qualité
des prestations servaient aux
administrés à notre sens tout ça
nécessite une approche méthodique ferme
engagée domaine par domaine si on veut
que chaque euro d’apôtres cotisation
soit utilement dépensé dans l'intérêt
nos concitoyens nous avons examiné
quatre domaines qui pour chacun d'eux de
marge d'amélioration les deux premiers
concernent le champ de la santé de
l'assurance maladie dont j'ai déjà
souligné qu'il doit construire un
terrain de rêve en prioritaire nous
savons tous ça vient dans le sens de ce
que je viens de dire à l'instant combien
la situation de l'hôpital public qui
appelle des efforts particuliers les
personnels appellent des mesures
notamment d'organisation de gestion de
répartition plus des moyens de
meilleures conditions de travail sont
nécessaires pour que leur engagement
dont on a vu à quel point il était
formidable puisse s'exprimer librement
donc on peut se faire faire des
économies à l'hôpital sur le
numérisation mais il y a aussi des
investissements à faire ils peuvent être
conséquents notre conviction c'est
qu'une autre clé se trouve du côté de la
médecine libérale dont les activités
interagissent nous avons choisi pour
cela
d'illustrer notre propos par deux
activités distinctes la radiologie et la
radiothérapie qui mettent en fait en
exergue des problématiques assez
similaires d'abord une répartition
territoriale satisfaisante
des postures d'évaluation et prise en
charge de l'innovation limitée
troisièmement des actions insuffisantes
d'amélioration de patience des actes
ensuite une connaissance sommaire des
activités réalisées et de leurs côtes et
enfin une adéquation de la tarification
des activités avec un impact sur les
rémunérations des personnes
professionnelles qui continuent une
perte d'attractivité tout à fait
préoccupante pour l'hôpital nous pensons
que des réponses doivent être apportées
rapidement à ces problématiques un autre
exemple concerne un aspect majeur pour
les qualités de la prise en charge ou de
l'accompagnement nous concitoyens âgés
ou en situation de handicap il s'agit
des conditions de travail des personnels
du secteur médico-social que nous avons
analysé de manière inédite à travers le
prisme des accidents du travail de
maladies professionnelles et ça redouble
le message que j'ai détenu porter ici la
fréquence des accidents ou des maladies
ou qu'elles sont exposées les salariés
de certaines catégories d'établissements
notamment sur les EHPAD les trois fois
supérieurs à se constater dans
l'ensemble des secteurs la cabines tout
entière nous avons montré que
l'amélioration progressive du tout
d'encadrement c'est-à-dire le nombre de
salariés disponibles pour prendre en
charge et accompagner les personnes
permettraient non seulement d'améliorer
la qualité des services qui leur sont
rendus mais aussi de réduire fortement
le nombre des accidents d'autres termes
nous avons détecté une sorte de cercle
vicieux de l'économie aveugle qui
enclenche dépend supplémentaires ce qui
veut dire aussi qu'il y a des dépenses
vertueuses qui peuvent enclencher des
économies fortes mieux vaut dépenser au
bon endroit pour renforcer le taux
d'encadrement et pour aussi minimiser
les conséquences des absences je me
permets d'ajouter en vue de vos débats
sur le PLFSS 2023 que la Cour est au
service de votre commission pour
renforcer la transparence et la
régulation financière des établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes les EHPAD
comme vous le savez
l'indépendance de la cour fait toute la
force de ces analyses et de ses
recommandations lors de la présentation
devant vous de l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes sur la médicalisation des EHPAD
réaliser à votre demande j'ai pris
publiquement position pour regretter les
limites actuelles de la compétence et
juridiction financière en la matière la
mauration du contrôle passe aussi par
l'extension des compétences des
autorités constitutionnelles de contrôle
aujourd'hui l'utilisation des recettes
d'hébergement échappent au contrôle de
la Cour et des chambres Giens étaient à
des comptes je forme le vœu devant vous
que le lisateur fasse évoluer le champ
de compétences de la cour et les CRTC
dès ce pdfss il en va de la formation du
citoyen de notre possibilité de
contrôler au sein de l'établissement et
du groupe les produits d'hébergement et
les postes de charges qu'ils financent
je poste notamment à l'immobilier et aux
achats
il me semble qu'après les scandales que
nous avons connu après les analyses que
nous avons faites il est indispensable
de renforcer le contrôle sur les EHPAD
et j'ai la faiblesse de penser que la
Cour est loin d'être la plus mal placée
pour ne pas dire qu'elle est la mieux
placée pour ce faire je suis à votre
dispositions pour discuter d'un projet
d'amendement si vous étiez d'accord je
vous ferai repasser les les éléments la
matière ça avait été envisagé si bien
compris dans le projet initial du
gouvernement puis retirer parce qu'il y
a peut-être des problèmes juridiques
qu'il faut pouvoir traiter il y a moyen
de le faire j'en suis persuadé
les scandales que nous avons connus
montrent que ce secteur a besoin
vraiment d'être mieux contrôlé et au
service des citoyens et en aide au
Parlement la cour est bien placée pour
le faire elle est volontaire pour le
faire tout ce dont on va faire plus en
la matière mais ça dépend là d'une
disposition législative qui me semble
pouvoir être réintroduite utilement avec
l'accord sans doute du gouvernement
d'ailleurs et de l'Assemblée nationale
j'en suis sûr on peut trouver la bonne
jauge pendant ce débat
dernier exemple d'amélioration de la
qualité et de l'efficience concernant
l'aspect mal connu de notre système de
retraite il s'agit des droits familiaux
attribués aux parents et au titre de
leurs enfants ces droits représentent
près de 20 milliards de dépenses
annuelles ils ont été institués il y a
50 ans ou plus elle n'est pas coulée
famille était plus nombreuses et où les
maires en particulier travaillaient
considérablement moins ces dispositifs
complexes accordent des trimestres mais
sans compenser suffisamment les pertes
de salaire subies justement par les
maires nous recommandons une remise à
plat pour corriger cette injustice sans
dépenses nouvelles madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs pour
conclure je veux revenir sur le message
principal du rapport il est à nos yeux
impératifs de mettre fin d'accroissement
continu de la dette sociale en remettant
rapidement la sécurité sociale sur un
chemin effectif d'équilibre financier
pour cela il convient de ne pas s'en
tenir aux perspectives aléatoires de
croissance des activités économiques
dont dépend des recettes sociales
mais aussi d'entreprendre les réformes
nécessaires d'une entreprise cession
sociale qu'il s'agisse des retraites
elles ne sont pas au cœur de notre
rapport malgré l'actualité que nous
connaissons mais nous devons des
positions sur le sujet qui ne sont pas
inconnues mais aussi l'organisation de
notre système de santé en rendant ainsi
les dépenses plus efficientes et dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres c'est
maintenant la qualité de la dépense
pardon de me répéter qui est impérative
non pas l'austérité aveugle mais la
dépense bien calibrée au bon endroit
c'est la forme sont d'abord nécessaires
pour garantir la pérennité de notre
système de retraite l'accès à tous de
soins de qualité sans réduire les
niveaux de prise en charge par
l'assurance maladie c'est je crois ce
qu'attendre concitoyens merci pour votre
attention et je me tiens avec les
magistrats qui m'entourent à votre
disposition pour répondre dans la mesure
de mes capacités à vos interrogations
merci monsieur le Président et merci de
votre appui future sur le texte que nous
attendons concernant concernant
notamment le médico-social et les
personnes âgées
après l'audition qui que nous avions eu
ensemble sur la médicalisation des EHPAD
au collègues Bernard bonne et je me dis
enfin un rapport spécifique
lié un peu à ce qui était l'affaire
Orbea pour résumer de façon un peu
réductrice
l'idée du rapport mais je pense qu'en
effet il y aura des choses à faire alors
je vais passer la parole au rapporteur
du PLFSS
donc Elisabeth Doisneau et ensuite
chaque rapport
pourra vous poser des questions
Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour l'ensemble de
votre diagnostic et je voudrais partager
ces remerciements avec tous ceux qui
vous accompagnent et ceux qui ont
travaillé sur l'ensemble de ces dossiers
vous avez en quelque sorte dressées le
portrait optimiste
de ce qui nous est présenté à travers le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale je pense tout comme
vous qu'il est peu réaliste et en
réalité
si
qualifié de pluraliste on peut dire
aussi que
dans un certain sens on est un peu comme
la cigale qui chantait tout l'été alors
que on devrait comme vous le dites si
bien être plutôt sur pas l'économie la
mauvaise dépense mais la dépense de
qualité et je crois qu'il faut en tout
cas si si comment pencher je voudrais en
tout cas vous dire que vous observations
qui sont relatives à l'inexactitude des
comptes pour l'exercice 2021 sont
éclairantes et nous conduisent à
relativiser la forte amélioration des
comptes de la Sécurité sociale de
l'année dernière
pour l'avenir j'aurais donc deux
questions
la première c'est estimez-vous que la
trajectoire financière
2023-2026 qui a été d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure montré
et crédible pour
notre appréciation en tout cas un autre
mais aussi pour les explications pour
qu'on pourrait y apporter et en
particulier en regard de l'évolution des
recettes et de celle des dépenses de la
branche maladie et vous l'avez souligné
à plusieurs reprises qui peuvent
paraître très optimistes ma deuxième
question c'est est-ce que cette même
trajectoire qui fait apparaître des
déficits de plus en plus lourd sur la
branche vieillesse invite à penser
qu'une réforme des retraites
correctement calibrées
suffirait à ramener la sécurité sociale
à un équilibre financier global et même
envisager une extinction de la Cadès
pour 2033
la cour partage-t-elle cette approche ou
êtes-vous un petit peu plus comment en
retrait par rapport à cette
remarque merci
vous répondez
distinguant la rapporteur oh peut-être
le rapporteurs
dans un premier temps vous m'interrogez
sur la crédibilité l'état financière qui
accompagne le PDFs 2023 notamment celle
de la branche maladie
j'ai en fait déjà un peu répondu mais je
vais détailler le projet loi de
financement la sécurité sociale pour
2023 prévoit une diminution très forte
de la sécurité sociale moins de 7
milliards d'euros 2023 contre 18
milliards en 2022
la croissance économique prévue dans le
cadre des différents projets de loi de
financement qui sont soumis à vos
assemblées me paraît optimiste elle est
encore à 1% avec une croissance mondiale
à 3,1%. alors que la plupart des
instituts s'accordent avec la croissance
mondiale risque inférieur à 2% et la
croissance française le consensus est
actuellement aussi pour cent il ne cesse
plutôt de se dégrader donc
indépendamment de cette incertitude
général et elle existe tout de même
il y a un risque
à niveau sensiblement plus élevé et ça
ne peut pas être écarté les prévisions
apparaissent notamment très très
optimistes pour la branche maladie par
exemple ça suppose notamment qu'elle
dépense de tests covid divisé par 20 par
rapport 2021 nous le souhaitons tous
bien sûr mais comment dire c'est quand
même assez volontariste comme objectif
par ailleurs sur le PLFSS la croissance
des dépenses structurales c'est-à-dire
hors covid
ça supposerait des dépenses d'ajustement
significatif d'avoir des professionnels
des professionnels de santé ce qui est
loin d'être acquis si on regarde le
passé c'est pas du tout ce qui se
produit en fait d'habitude et puis les
perspectives 2023 2026 qui ont dans le
BFC sont très incertaines elles sont peu
étéies à ce stade le projet de détails
ni moyen du redressement de la
branche maladie ni ceux visant à
contenir la dégradation difficile à
branche vieillesse en toute état de
cause les perspectives présentées par le
PLFSS prenons même l'hypothèse où ça se
vérifierait ce qui nous paraoptimiste
montre que le déficit global là si vous
êtes social resterait durablement
dégradé et pour des montants quand même
très élevés près de 12 milliards d'euros
en 2026 dans une trajectoire qui est
encore une fois nous paraît
plutôt favorable et l'absence durable de
redressement est en soit très
préoccupante je rappelle que la sécurité
sociale ne peut pas rester durablement
efficace sans faire peser sur le futur
le financement des prestations
qui sont versés aujourd'hui et je
rappelle également l'exigence
constitutionnelle qui s'attache à
l'équilibre financier la sécurité
sociale dont le respect contrôlé par le
Conseil constitutionnel vous avez aussi
sur l'impact qu'aurait une réforme des
retraites sur la situation financière la
sécurité sociale on vous demandant si
une réforme suffirait en réalité
résorbé déficit de la Sécu d'abord je me
souviens que l'étendue de la réforme des
retraites envisées par le gouvernement
n'est pas connu dans le détail mais en
tout hypothèse
cette réforme de produira ses effets que
progressivement quand bien même on
dirait vers ce que nous lisons tous dans
quelques années 64 ans dans 10 ans à peu
près un peu plus 65 ans ça ne permettra
pas d'éviter l'accroissement de la dette
sociale dans les quatre années qui
viennent et ça n'économisera pas de la
nécessité d'envisager un nouveau
transfert de dettes à la CADES dont la
durée de vie devrait être prolongée ce
qui veut dire que vous aurez en débattre
au plan législatif parce qu'il faut une
modification de cette nature nous avons
dit 2023
dans les deux années qui viennent
prolongation de la CADES au-delà de 2033
il n'est pas certain parieur que la
réforme soit suffisante pour ramener
durablement la branche retraite à
l'équipe financier en soi
mais donc notre conviction c'est que la
réforme des retraites qui doit être
documentée d'abord décider ensuite ça
suppose des concertations
mais en toute hypothèse ça laisse
entière les questions déficience et de
qualité des dépenses d'assurance maladie
ne pas considérer que c'est en quelque
sorte
une sorte de carte magique qui est le
seul suffirait à tout c'est à dire
renflouer les caisses de l'État les
caisses de la Sécurité sociale évitez
des réformes à côté non il faudra bien
aller vers plus efficient cette qualité
dans les dépenses masturbanisme c'est
pour ça que nous avons appelé un
traitement réformiste
méthode par méthode domaine par domaine
secteur par secteur et ça ne permet en
aucun cas madame dénuder les efforts
dans le domaine d'assurance maladie qui
devront être déterminés prolongés dans
les années qui viennent et largement de
là
merci monsieur le Président Corinne
Imbert remporte la branche maladie
ensuite je passerai la parole à René
Paul ça va aller
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président merci pour votre
présentation
j'ai plusieurs questions si vous le
permettez vous évoquez dans votre
rapport le rôle suffisant du
gouvernement dans l'encadrement des
négociations conventionnelles mais
également le relation suffisant du
Parlement en effet des enjeux importants
sont traités par voie réglementaires
alors même qu'ils ont un impact
particulièrement sensible sur sur les
dépenses sans que celle-ci ne soit donc
approuvée par le Parlement comment selon
vous renforcer le pouvoir du Parlement
sur le pilotage financier de l'assurance
maladie
deuxième question le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour 2023-2027 en temps renouvelé
même si ce n'était pas le cas jusqu'ici
une mise en réserve de 0,3% de lame
chaque année cette mise en réserve vous
semble-t-elle crédible et surtout
pertinente
à ce titre comment selon vous arrivez si
mise en réserve il y a à la rendre
effective sur l'ensemble des sous en
dames
dans le chapitre consacré à la à la
radiothérapie vous plaidez pour une
procédure d'autorisation temporaire
limitée dans le temps par définition des
techniques et pratiques innovantes en
radiothérapie conditionnées par un suivi
des situations cliniques quel mode de
financement selon vous pourrait convenir
à une telle hypothèse et enfin vous avez
évoqué dans votre présentation le fait
que les dépenses de médecine de ville
hors médicament et actes de biologie si
j'ai bien compris avait
triplé enfin en tout cas progresser
trois fois plus vite ces dernières
années quel lien faites-vous avec le
raccourcissement de la durée de séjour
des patients à l'hôpital je vous
remercie
de la branche vieillesse et président de
La Mecque oui merci merci monsieur le
Premier Président effectivement la
réforme des retraites elle doit pas être
là pour
combler les trous de la sécurité sociale
mais garantir un niveau de prestation
dans les années qui viennent et les
effets d'une réforme c'est toujours là
on c'est pour ça que plus en tard
d'apprendre les décisions plus les
effets sont brutaux c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ferons un certain nombre
de propositions et vous abordez dans ce
cadre là d'ailleurs les majorations de
pension par exemple une harmonisation
voilà une réforme des retraites c'est
pour ça que ça rapporte pas toujours que
sur le plan budgétaire ça doit aussi
amener des des prestations ou des effets
en tout cas de solidarité supplémentaire
pour la rendre acceptable bien entendu
et là il y a des possibilités je partage
votre point de vue d'harmoniser les
majorations de pension pour enfants
entre les régimes
et de les étendre même aux professions
libérales mais je voudrais savoir si
vous avez pu estimer le coût d'une
mesure comme celle-là
deuxièmement ce qui pond concerne les
APL on a eu l'occasion de faire une
mission là-dessus sur les recouvrements
et effectivement il y a 2 % de %
d'erreurs dans le calcul du de des
appels par rapport à la DSN et on voit
bien les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer sur la fiabilité des domaines
dénominatives par rapport aux données
agrégées et pensez vous que
la volonté de
du versement à la source des prestations
sociales la volonté gouvernementale
pensez-vous qu'elle puisse s'appliquer
dans les années qui viennent ou bien
est-ce que c'est un procédure qui sera
long pour pour avoir la garantie de
cette fiabilisation qui est à notre
point de vue pas encore au point et
toujours sur cette fiabilisation et
notamment le transfert des recouvrements
aux urssafs en ce qui concerne un
certain nombre d'organismes par exemple
Carco nous ne sommes pas favorables à ce
transfert recouvrement elle s'est bien
le faire vous proposez d'ailleurs et là
nous sommes pas je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vos propositions vous
proposez également de de transmettre
elle recouvrement des cotisations des
retraites des professions libérales or
les régimes professionnels sont des
régimes intégrés puisqu'ils font
actuellement et le recouvrement et la
prestation et on voit qu'en cas de crise
ils savent réagir vous proposez même de
l'étendre
éventuellement à la MSA or là aussi la
MSA c'est le guichet unique qui serait
remise en cause en cas de séparation
des missions de de recouvrement si on
est confié à l'URSSAF alors pensez-vous
pas que chaque fois on dirait cela
plutôt à fragiliser un système qui
fonctionne
on continue sur les branches merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci ainsi qu'à votre équipe
c'est pas un bon rapport c'est un très
bon rapport ce qui fait même que quand
on partage beaucoup des constats c'est
plus délicat encore de s'exprimer et de
trouver les questions pertinentes mais
bien évidemment le silence n'aurait pas
de beaucoup de sens mais moi lorsque
j'ai ouvert ce PLFSS et notamment sur la
trajectoire sans entrer dans le détail
immédiatement je me suis dit c'est comme
si on avait voulu
nous faire arriver à une conclusion
qui est la suivante il faut absolument
on voit bien dans la trajectoire une
réforme des retraites et il n'y a pas
d'urgence tout de suite pour réformer
l'assurance maladie or je pense que il
faut faire une réforme des retraites
bien évidemment on vit plus longtemps
donc difficile de de de
que il faudrait pas travailler plus
longtemps c'est une évidence
démographique finalement mais en
revanche j'ai du mal à croire que le
déficit de l'assurance maladie puisse
diminuer aussi rapidement et il me
semble que on aborde pas et qu'il faudra
aborder au moins aussi rapidement la
question de la réforme de la branche
maladie s'en sort qui était sur la
responsabilité de mes collègues mais
comme je reprendrai pas la parole je
m'exprime en tant que commissaire
au moins de manière aussi urgente que
que la réforme de l'assurance vieillesse
parce que la question chère à Jean-Marie
van laurenberg des actes redondants
d'une forme de surconsommation médicale
tout de même parfois il faudra un moment
ou un autre l'aborder de front c'est
faudra mes collègues chers collègues un
moment ou un autre l'aborder de front et
on voit bien que il y a des freins ici
et là pour aborder ces questions et que
finalement
on a quelques fois plus de facilité
c'est pas simple d'aborder la question
de la réforme de retraite que la
question de la réforme de la référence
maladie et de la surconsommation
médicale donc je voilà mon sentiment sur
ces questions maintenant sur la branche
famille bah oui je partage ton
totalement cette forme de confusion qui
existe et on le dit pas d'aujourd'hui
entre la page la prépare la CMG
qui rend difficile en plus
l'appréciation comme vous le dites de
l'incidence sur le coût final des modes
de garde c'est un c'est pas un mince
paradoxe on dépense beaucoup d'argent et
puis finalement il y a une faible
visibilité et et et
au fond les parents n'y voit pas clair
et je dirais même que il y a une il y a
une forme de fracture c'est à dire que
comme on n'est pas dans une prestation
unique on aboutit à ce que les familles
les plus modestes et plus davantage
financier à choisir les modes de garde
collectif et en revanche les familles
les plus favorisées vont parfois pour
des avantages fiscaux plus conséquents
vers le choix de des assistantes
maternelles et ça crée en plus un
problème de régulation comme vous l'avez
bien dit des de la de la régulation des
salaires des assistantes maternelles
voilà ma question elle est à la suivante
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut encore
par petites touches en modifiant ici et
là c'est c'est prestations mais que
qu'on puisse arriver à quelque chose de
plus juste de plus lisible de plus
efficaces les plus efficient de plus
incitatif et qu'il est pas temps d'avoir
une aide unique plus lisible plus plus
juste et qui aboutit à faire en sorte
que cette question de la garde des
enfants qui d'ailleurs pas très bien
traitée dans notre société parce que
quand on voit les freins à l'emploi avec
ma collègue puissant on étudie cette
question à l'occasion de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage on voit que souvent
pour un certain nombre de une femme
seule la question des modes de garde est
un réel frein à l'emploi et donc on n'a
pas non plus trouvé
le bon curseur ce problème voilà le
toutes les questions mais en saluant la
à nouveau la qualité du rapport merci
monsieur le Président merci alors encore
deux rapporteurs parce qu'elle connaît
pour la branche à thème TMP et ensuite
filer pour le Médico-Social
merci madame la Présidente
le premier président alors moi la
différence de mes collègues pour la
branche ATMP c'est qu'il faut souligner
permanence des excédents et c'est plutôt
de la bonne utilisation justement de ces
excédents à mes questions en tournée
quand même autour de ça sachant que en
plus les quarts entre les recettes et
les dépenses de la branche vont
continuer aussi à se creuser d'année en
année passant dans les prévisions deux
milliards d'euros en 2022 3,3 milliards
en 2027 26 pardon alors moi ma question
c'est par rapport aussi au dernier texte
que nous avons fait qui était plutôt axé
en matière de santé au travail sur la
prévention santé et accident du travail
donc est-ce que cette situation
financière donc des avec des excédents
on pourrait pas davantage
l'engager sur des dépenses nouvelles
en faveur de la prévention justement des
accidents du travail maladie
professionnelle ou alors une baisse des
cotisations pour les employeurs
alors ensuite sur une deuxième question
j'en ai trois voilà le rapport de sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale formule la
proposition de regrouper dans une même
branche l'ensemble des prestations en
espèces versées par l'assurance maladie
au titre du risque d'arrêt de travail
qu'il s'agisse des maladies ordinaires
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle alors c'est vrai que ça
aurait le mérite de mettre fin au
transfert
de chaque année de la branche à TMP à la
branche maladie au titre de la
soudéclaration qui est quand même
quelque chose qui est peu transparent
voire très opaque et fixé à 1,2
milliards d'euros dans le PLFSS encore
pour 2023 alors est-ce que vous pourriez
préciser en quoi un tel regroupement
serait plus cohérent
resterait-il selon vous plus efficace
d'étendre le principe de la modulation
en fonction de la sinistralité au
cotisations finançant les indemnités
journalières pour maladies et les
cotisations sociales seraient-elles
suffisantes pour financer cette branche
élargie
alors un chapitre du rap pour du rapport
de la Cour et consacrée à la maîtrise
des risques professionnels dans les
établissements et services pour les
personnes âgées et personnes en
situation de handicap vous avez souligné
tout à l'heure où la sinistralité donc
apparaît particulièrement élevé alors le
rapport se prononce en faveur
d'incitation financière individualisée
en fonction de la sinistralité de chaque
structure alors que le secteur se voit
actuellement appliquer un taux de
cotisation ATMP collectif avez-vous
connaissance de précédents changements
de régime de cette nature dans d'autres
secteurs d'activité et quels
enseignements peut-on en tirer et
comment procéder à un tel changement
sans mettre en péril les structures ni
augmenter le reste à charge des
usagers
l'efficacité de cette tarification ne
serait-elle pas compromise par
l'impossibilité de l'appliquer au
secteur public merci beaucoup
merci Madame grenier et pour terminer
Philippe mouiller pour les rapporteurs
préliminaires vous nous avez fait un
vous avez décrit une situation plutôt
inquiétante aujourd'hui de l'ensemble
des comptes et j'aurais un pas sur le le
peu de crédibilité que nous accordons
tous les cas sur le budget de cette
année notamment regarde des recettes qui
nous semblent plutôt plus élevées que la
réalité est certainement un certain
nombre de dépenses qui seraient
certainement sous-estimé mais dans les
perspectives que vous avez donné vous
avez évoqué notamment 2026 un déficit
estimé autour de 12 milliards d'euros ma
question c'est est-ce que les enjeux de
la branche autonomie avec le débat du
vieillissement finalement sont intégrés
dans cette perspective parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de réforme
il n'y a pas de proposition il y a
simplement une abondance budgétaire des
outils existants et la vraie question
c'est aujourd'hui et bien comment
financer au-delà de la CSG comment
financer l'évolution concernant la
broche autonomie et plus grand que ça un
impact direct sur la trajectoire que
vous présentez et certainement de façon
relativement importante étant donné le
vieillissement de la population c'était
mon préambule ensuite deux questions
plus techniques vous avez fait un zoom
sur les accidents du travail et
notamment la situation notamment dans
médico-social avec un taux d'accident
trophées supérieur à la moyenne
nationale et vous avez fait un détail
entre les établissements et le domicile
ma question est-ce que vous pensez que
cette situation a un impact direct sur
l'attractivité du métier du secteur et
concernant notamment le domicile qui a
des enjeux fondamental quelle piste la
cour recommande-t-elle d'explorer pour
être en mesure de répondre aux enjeux et
notamment à l'évolution politique était
proposée par le gouvernement ensuite
concernant le contrôle des EHPAD nous
avons bien noté aujourd'hui la volonté
commune d'avoir un contrôle qui soit
plus approfondie situation est-ce que
vous pensez que aujourd'hui les
propositions qui ont été votées
cet été puis les propositions nouvelles
sont en mesure d'avoir une vision
précise des flux financiers notamment
pour les groupes parce que c'est le
point particulier vous évoquez notamment
les dérives et pour nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est d'avoir une vision sur
des fonctions des groupes gestionnaires
des pads vous avez ensuite évoqué la
volonté des temps de le regard sur le
fonctionnement de la section
d'hébergement pourquoi pas la question
peut être posée sur la table mais je
pense qu'en parallèle le débat sur la
fongibilité des sections pour être un
débat qui soit traité de la même façon
parce que quand on a un contrôle global
et peut-être une piste d'évolution du
fonctionnement des établissements
c'est le premier président nous en avons
terminé avec les auditions des
rapporteurs des questions des
rapporteurs donc si vous souhaitez
répondre ensuite nous aurons de
collègues
je prends tout alors Jean-Marie
la présidente monsieur le Premier
Président bon comme à la coutumée on ne
peut que vous remercier de cet excellent
rapport
qui est plein qui est nourrit de votre
expérience évidemment et surtout qui
présente quelques pistes intéressantes
on en discute qu'on vient jamais
là moi je reviens sur ce que d'ailleurs
rappelé Olivier Hainaut sur un certain
nombre
je dirais navarian ce qui me concerne
les soins inutiles au dondants on les a
chiffrés entre 20 et 30 % suivant
effectivement les évaluateurs c'est
plutôt 30 selon certains un peu moins
pour d'autres vous avez effectivement
dans le rapport
ciblé la radiothérapie notamment je sais
que dans le PLFSS le gouvernement visage
de réduire les dépenses en termes de
radiologie de biologie
c'est un c'est pas le premier pas
d'ailleurs puisqu'il y en a déjà eu mais
ça me paraît insuffisant au regard
effectivement des enjeux rappelle que
20% sur 230 milliards de dépenses ça
fait 46 milliards et plus si c'est 30
c'est de la mathématique simple donc
pour moi les efforts sont à faire là
pour améliorer effectivement
l'équilibre de l'assurance maladie
sur les retraites il y a un autre sujet
aussi ce sont les fraudes sociales
sur l'assurance maladie
sur les recommandations que vous aviez
formulées précédemment
feuilles de route a été engagée par le
gouvernement
et nous avons constaté que si certaines
caisses si souscrit volontiers c'est
lent voire trop lent du côté de
l'assurance maladie on a eu qu'un seul
retour portant sur 15 milliards de
dépenses avec si je me souviens bien 500
millions
d'estimations de fraudes
je dirais est-ce que vous ne croyez pas
qu'il faille donner un coup
d'accélérateur dans ce domaine je ne
l'ai pas j'ai à peine perçu
effectivement que vous évoquez le sujet
peut-être qu'il faudrait effectivement
insister un peu plus auprès de
l'assurance maladie sur ce point et le
dernier dernière question concerne les
retraites bon c'est vrai que le débat va
s'engager sur sur les
âges de départ sur l'accélération de la
durée de cotisation
j'ai lu récemment un avis qui me paraît
assez autorisé celui de Monsieur Lorenzi
économiste que vous connaissez bien et
qui dit il y a surtout à faire
travailler plus que tout le monde
personne ne dit d'ailleurs et le travail
des seigneurs s'amène effectivement plus
de recettes
et je crois que c'est peut-être vers
cela qu'il faut aussi s'engager j'ai pas
trouvé dans votre rapport sur ce point
effectivement d'éléments précis donc
voilà mes questions sur le premier
président
merci Madame à présent monsieur le
Président merci pour ce rapport pour
cette excellent rapport si je dois vous
dire quand même que si je partage le
constat je demande à être convaincu sur
certaines des propositions que vous
pouvez faire
je reviens donc maintenant sur la
question que je vais vous poser
sur la durabilité du système actuel
honnêtement est-ce qu'on peut envisager
sérieusement que système puisse encore
exister longtemps quand on constate
c'est difficile constant qui sont de
plus en plus à mon avis dangereux
d'autant plus dangereux que la cadèse
qui est chargée de rembourser l'ensemble
de ces emprunts elle-même empreinte avec
un taux d'usure qui est de plus en plus
haut et de plus en plus dangereux pour
l'ensemble
on peut aussi voir que
l'assurance maladie à des frais de
gestion pour traiter un dossier et les
eaux-cames à côté ont des frais de
gestion pour traiter le même dossier
est-il normal que chacun dans son coin
traite les dossiers et des frais de
gestion alors qu'on pourrait très bien
envisager que ce dossier puisse être
traité pour tout le monde en même temps
et puis si on constate des fluctuations
de recettes en permanence pour
l'assurance maladie les ocames elles ont
moins ont l'avantage de pouvoir
augmenter régulièrement leur cotisations
sans que d'ailleurs personne ne met
aucune contradiction et aucun râle sur
le sujet alors ma question est simple
monsieur le Président quelle est la
solution est-ce qu'on continue de faire
vivre côte à côte l'assurance maladie
d'un côté n'est aucun de l'autre en
parallèle ou est-ce qu'on essaie de
faire en sorte que chacun ait son
domaine bien précis avec une
transparence constante et dans les
recettes et dans les dépenses
pour terminer Michel meunier si même la
présidente merci monsieur le Premier
Président
de la qualité de votre travail et de la
présentation moi je vais me focaliser
simplement sur les EHPAD et la
sinistralité que vous nous avez présenté
par slide là j'ai fait une photo donc
trois fois
les arrêts de travail trois fois
supérieur à la moyenne
nationale donc oui sur c'est c'est hors
norme et parmi les propositions donc
vous vous
favorisez le regroupement c'est Philippe
mouiller la évoqué or dans le rapport
que nous avons fait avec Bernard bonne
le regroupement est parfois enfin
l'affaire européen ou l'a montré source
de d'opacité on va dire ça comme ça et
de difficultés de
d'examen de contrôle
de ces regroupements qui sont parfois un
peu
tentaculaire donc ça c'était une
première question que je subordonnée à
une proposition qu'on vous faisait
c'est-à-dire détendre les compétences de
la chambre au contrôle de la section
hébergement des EHPAD qui pour l'instant
donc quand il s'agit des pas de privés à
bullycratif ne sont pas du tout
examinés ni contrôler par aucun qu'un
corps de contrôle donc je n'avais pas le
retour nous n'avons pas eu le retour de
cette proposition de d'élargissement de
des compétences de la chambre la chambre
la Cour des comptes bien sûr mais aussi
les Chambres régionales
et puis dans l'autre la c'est moi une
question mais un commentaire l'autre
recommandation que vous faites c'est de
se rapprocher de un pour un
professionnel pour aux chevets d'un
patient d'un malade et donc vous en fait
même le calcul d'une économie de 32%
presque 33% donc voilà donc ça ça
corrobore tout à fait ce que nous sommes
très nombreux à demander ici à la fois
pour la qualité de l'accueil mais aussi
pour la qualité du travail et des
professionnels dans le secteur du
médico-social merci
si monsieur le Premier Président
beaucoup de questions donc je vous
propose de répondre dans l'ordre ou dans
le système
dans l'ordre d'abord commençons par les
questions de Madame Humbert sur les les
dépenses maladies la question de
l'encadrement des dépenses prévues par
les conventions signées par l'assurance
maladie à la question de la mise en
œuvre pour les soins de ville de
dispositif de régulation en cas de
dépassement il faut d'abord vous assurer
que je partage vos préoccupations
l'endroit de l'évolution des dépenses de
soins de ville sur les dix dernières
années j'ai cité ce chiffre je le recite
les dépenses de soins de ville ont
évolué trois fois plus vite que
l'inflation je précise en dehors de ça
des médicaments les dépenses de biologie
qui elles ont été strictement encadrées
du mois jusqu'à la crise sanitaire nous
serons d'accord sur le fait que chaque
euro que la collectivité consacre à la
santé de la population doit être dépensé
à bon escient ce qu'on appelle les soins
de ville représente plus de la moitié de
dépenses de lambda mais les honoraires
de profession libérales sont en train de
près de 40% des dépenses votre compte
ville il faut donc se pencher sur la
façon dont ces dépenses évoluent dans un
point de vue quantitatif que qualitatif
votre question porte sur l'encadrement
quantitatif je vais y répondre mais
avec moi que l'enjeu est aussi
capitalitatif comment mieux dépenser sur
le plan de qualitatif j'observe que
l'annexe B au pffss fixe la trajectoire
des dépenses d'assurance maladie
globalement sont distinguées la ville ou
l'hôpital ce qui n'est pas la solution
et j'observe aussi que le LPF de votre
programmation de finance publique fixe
la trajectoire des soins de ville mais
cette enveloppe est plus large que celle
des dépenses fixées par les conventions
signées par l'assurance maladie c'est
pourquoi nous proposons dans le Ralph
que les objectifs plus réels de dépenses
par convention soit rendu public à
l'étude est négociations et qu'un suivi
régulier du coup détaillé et complet de
chaque convention soit mis en place pour
permettre notamment au Parlement tant
assuré le contrôle proposons également
que les dispositifs qui existent
juridiquement soient effectivement mis
en oeuvre lorsque déplacement sont
prévisibles les mesures de
revalorisation tarifaires favorables au
profil du bureau doivent être reportées
jusqu'à un an comme la loi le prévoit
vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur la
radiothérapie comment financer les actes
innovants je crois qu'il faut les
financer par les dotations
d'investissement hadoc qui soit
contrôlables sur le dépenses de médecine
de ville j'ai déjà en partie répondu
mais il est clair qu'il y a tout de même
un lien entre leur développement et
celui de la politique ambilatoire et
l'accélération des dépenses et soins de
ville mais pas dans les proportions
observées en toute état de cause les
dépenses des cliniques privées
augmentent rapidement donc envisager une
régulation pour les soins de ville et
pour les soins en établissement voilà on
peut les réponses que je souhaitais
faire
les questions de Monsieur Savary
sur
on va lui poser trois questions monsieur
le rapporteur
celle d'abord de l'extension des
majorations de pension pour enfants au
retraités libérales écoute cette mesure
d'abord souligner que les règles
d'attribution des majorations de
pensions pour enfants sont différentes
selon les régimes qui les verse pour les
retraités qui ont relevé de plusieurs
régimes durant leur carrière ça entraîne
les différents situations peu
compréhensibles sources sentiment
peut-être de réalité d'ailleurs
d'iniquité nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire d'abord d'aligner ces
majorations de pension sur la base d'un
même taux de 10% ensuite de supprimer
les sur-maturations existantes dans les
régimes spéciaux dont celui la fonction
publique enfin de plafonner le montant
total perçu par retraité de ces
différentes caisses sur le principe
appliqué déjà par la jrco c'est lorsque
nouveau cadre qu'il serait possible
d'envisager l'extension de ces
majorations caisse de retraite et pour
libérales de la sorte notre système
gagnerait en simplicité en efficacité
tout en permettant la maîtrise des
dépenses
votre deuxième question porte sur les
conditions de mise en œuvre
pardon
je crois pas que nous ayons d'estimation
précise mais on n'a pas on l'a pas
estimé mais je note la question et on
reviendra dès que ce sera fait sur les
conséquences qu'il y a tirées sur le
versement la source des prestations
sociales voulu par prise dans la
République d'abord je voudrais souligner
l'intérêt de la réforme des aPL en
premier lieu elle a permis de rapprocher
le montant des prestations versées de
celui des ressources des foyers puisque
les versements des appels désormais
calculées sur les ressources du
trimestre précédent de versement non pas
sur les bases fiscales de l'année L-2
comme c'était le cas jusqu'en 2020 en
second lieu c'était faire des économies
autour de 1,1 milliard d'euros en 2021
cependant 200 000 familles tout de même
ont subi des ruptures de versement dit
nombrables erreurs ont été commises les
caisses allocations familiales de
recruter plus de 2000 agents pour
corriger manuellement certains des
versements ces dysfonctionnements
montrent qu'un calcul intégralement
automatique réalisé à partir d'une
salaire de la DSN et des prestations
sociales ne peut s'envisager de toutes
les précautions qui étaient prises au
préalable ce qui n'a pas été le cas
évidence pour la réforme des aPL il faut
donc tirer les enseignements de cette
réforme et c'est les gars la voie
d'expérimentation rendue par le
gouvernement pour ajuster le versement
du RSA et de prime d'activité ou
derrière ressources que lui est une
approche qui me semble plutôt
raisonnable et ça devrait sans doute
inspirer la forme future dans le champ
de prestation sociale votre troisième
question porte sur le transfert aux
urssafs de la gestion du recouvrement
des cotisations de de
verser par les professionnels libéraux
alors caisse de retraite nous pensons
effectivement que l'exemple réussi la
transformation du RSI nous doit être une
source d'inspiration pour la gestion de
la sécurité sociale des autres
indépendants libéraux ou exploitants
agricoles
[Musique]
s'assurer nous l'avons constaté pour les
axes assurés du RSI alors Monsieur
Hainaut vous avez commencé par
considération générale sur les retraites
en réalité je partage largement même si
c'est pas dans le rapport
la réforme des retraites les courses n'y
revient pas dans le détail dans ce
rapport mais c'est déjà prononcé
nous sommes de ceux qui estiment qu'il y
a bien un problème de soutenabilité à
long terme de notre système de retraite
et qu'il faut le réformer pour assurer
son financement durable après il y a des
tas de façon de le faire mais elles
reviennent finalement toujours une
alternative soit les actifs pas plus
tard en retraite soit on baisse les
pensions et il me paraît quand même
largement préférable dans un contexte où
l'allongement de la durée de vie ce
qu'on est dégradation du rapport actif
inactif et ce qu'on connaît
de procéder par la première voie que par
la seconde
je trouve qu'en réalité il est beaucoup
plus antisocial
de refuser une réforme que de l'affaire
d'un certain point de vue mais ça c'est
un point de vue de tout personnel que je
retire immédiatement en tout cas
je pense que
on ne peut pas attendre d'une réforme
des retraites qu'elle soit une sorte de
couteau suisse
elle veut pas poursuivre 10 objectifs
elle ne peut pas à la fois participer au
redressement des finances publiques
augmenter la croissance et l'emploi
et réduire les déficits et en même temps
nous dispenser de tout autre réforme non
ça je sais pas comment on fait surtout
avec des réformes qui fatalement on les
effects qui seront très progressifs dans
le temps pour le mieux et donc non je
crois qu'il faut pas percer quiconque
d'illusion cette réforme de retraite
elle doit se faire elle doit se faire
dans des conditions que nous avons
rappelé nous entourer d'expertise
procéder à des concertation
et mettre en place une application qui
soit suffisamment étalé pour permettre
une bonne acceptation par la Société des
mesures prises bon dans ce contexte là
nous sommes obligés je dis bien obligé
de traiter aussi la question des
dépenses maladies c'est sinon on a
l'impression que tout se réduit à ça ça
n'est pas exact je ne crois vraiment pas
après vous avez posé des questions dans
le cadre de votre rôle de rapporteur
sur la question la guerre des enfants et
je partage votre avis laquelle des
enfants est un des anges centraux de la
politique familiale il faut y apporter
une très grande attention vu son impact
pour les familles pour les finances
publiques je rappelle que près de 15
milliards d'euros sont dépensés chaque
année par les politiques publiques
d'accueil du jeune enfant d'abord la
question fiscale et sociale en matière
de politique familiale
nous voyons que des progrès sont faits
ne serait-ce que du point de vue de la
simplification de facilitation pour les
familles mais ça devrait toujours être
la priorité pour nos citoyens simplifier
nous recommandons que le crédit d'impôt
pour garde d'enfants bénéfice
directement en famille en même temps que
le CMG dans sa réponse au directeur de
Lacoste nous a confirmé que ce service
sera ouvert dans moins de deux ans vous
m'interrogez ensuite sur la disposition
du pdfss qui prévoit des mécanismes pour
atténuer les effets des seuils des
barèmes du complément du libre choix du
mode de garde le CMG
la disposition du PLFSS va clairement
dans le bon sens il est souhaitable
d'éviter une forme de ségrégation
sociale de l'accueil des jeunes enfants
je vais cependant deux observations
complémentaires je note que la
disposition de PFC va plus loin que ce
que nous proposions pour les familles
monoportales en allongeant jusqu'au 12
ans de l'enfant au lieu de 6 le bénéfice
du CMG en majorant la prestation pour
cette famille
il y a une logique forte cibler les
familles monoportail mais c'est quand
même là pour le coup c'est large je n'ai
également que l'ensemble des
dispositions prévues par le PDFs sont
coûteuses j'ai cité le chiffre tout à
l'heure je le répète 600 millions on
avait plein en 2026 et nous grattons à
cet égard que ces évolutions qui sont
nécessaires aussi ne soient pas
accompagnées d'une réforme concomitante
du régime du
le prépare comme nous le recommandons
pour rendre plus cohérent les
dispositifs et pour atténuer les coûts
enfin vous m'interrogez sur
l'opportunité de réguler davantage le
salaire des assistances maternelles je
dois cependant que le versement du CMG
est déjà conditionné au fait que ce
salaire soit inférieur à 5 SMIC horaire
par jour et par enfant ce qui constitue
une première limitation qui est
significative mais dans le système
actuel le montant du CMG de plus en plus
plafonné de façon différenciée selon les
revenus des parents et selon nos enfants
dans le nouveau système envisagé
l'assistante maternelles pour être
tentés de se rapprocher davantage du
plafond de Sam SMIC aussi nous avons
préconisé un système de régulation plus
ajusté sans pour autant prendre position
sur ces modalités détaillées qui
relèveront des textes réglementaires
d'administration madame Grigny m'a
également posé trois questions
auxquelles je vais m'efforcer de
répondre d'abord
les deux premières questions mares
m'apparaît
contractuel concernant les excédents le
président du gouvernement montre
effectivement une poursuite de la
croissance excédents de la branche ATMP
qui passerait 1,3 milliards en 2021 3,3
milliards en 2026 deuxième point il y a
des liens financiers entre les branches
maladie ATMP nous savons que certaines
dépenses en réalité de la Manche ATMP ça
représenterait en 2021 entre 1,2 et 2,1
milliard d'euros et un transfert
financier compense en partie cette
charge indus pour la branche maladie
portée à 1,2 milliards d'euros en 2023
dans le PSS qui est celui du troisième
point la durée moyenne des arrêts de
travail pour ATMP et très dépendant du
secteur d'activité des salariés ce qui
est compréhensible mais la durée moyenne
l'est aussi ce qui est plus surprenant
il y a donc une logique forte envisagée
comme nous le recommandons une
approjection du risque commune vous
arrêtez de travail pour maladie pour
ATMP
page 146 du rapport
quatrième point enfin l'évolution des
invités journalières est extrêmement
préoccupante puisque hors covid en 10
ans entre 2012 et 2011 les dépenses
arrêtent de travail sont passées de 8,8
à 13 milliards d'euros auprès de 50%.
d'augmentation contre seulement 30% pour
la dame total autant dire que gestion du
risque n'a pas été efficace dans le
domaine arrêt de travail la priorité
serait donc de prévenir d'allongement à
justifier des arrêts ce sont les faits
les arrêts longs qui tirent les dépenses
vers le haut sont aussi les
plus pénalisants pour les salariés en
les éloignant du travail et en réduisant
leur chance de reprendre une activité
professionnelle et ça pèse aussi sur la
retraite je vais venir un petit peu plus
tard ça s'appelle la prévention de la
désinsertion professionnelle voilà
l'ensemble des raisons qui ont poussé la
cour à propos de rassembler dans une
même roche de gestion les prestations en
espèces malades et ATMP qui figure
d'ailleurs dans un rapport se serait de
travail établi en 2017 à trois experts à
la demande du Premier ministre
vous m'interrogez aussi sur notre
formation de soumettre les
établissements médico-sociaux un taux de
cotisation du récit ATMP qui tiennent
compte du risque réel de chaque
gestionnaire d'établissement il faut
rappeler que les salariés du secteur
médico-social en trois fois plus de
risques et de victimes d'un accident du
travail et d'une
série de l'ensemble de ces données je
dis bien trois fois plus c'est 30% de
plus que les entreprises du BTP c'est
donc dire à quoi on exposé alors que ce
sont des secteurs qui sont pourtant
connus pour leur pénibilité et leur
dangerosité et c'est pour ça que il faut
faire évoluer le système avec
progressivité et prudence pour éviter
d'évangules surcoût à la charte des
résidents mais nous avons préconisé là
dessus des investissements et ça rejoint
tout ce que nous avons pu dire sur ces
établissements
monsieur Mouilly à travers trois
réponses trois questions vous m'avez
interrogé en fait sur deux thématiques
différentes que je vais aborder
successivement
d'abord comme Madame Grigny vous
interrogez au fond sur le caractère hors
norme révélé par notre enquête des
risques arrêts de travail auxquels sont
exposées les salades du secteur des
établissement médico-sociaux
je veux pas revenir sur ce risque trois
fois plus c'est considérable et c'est
une situation vraiment catastrophique
qui est au cœur du défaut d'attractivité
du secteur qui n'est pas qu'un enjeu de
niveau de salaire et oui ça doit appeler
des mesures vigoureuses sur deux plans
d'abord la prévention qui doit mobiliser
les employeurs d'une part et les
administrations d'autre part dont les
ARS bien sûr ensuite le recrutement de
personnels supplémentaires oui il faut
recruter plus de personnes dans les
EHPAD ça peut paraître inhabituel que la
Cour appelle des recrutements
supplémentaires ça allait sans doute
mais elle est dans son rôle lorsqu'elle
appelle son relâche chercher les marges
déficient dans les dépenses publiques
c'est aussi pour contribuer au
financement des dépenses supplémentaires
là où elles sont nécessaires et dans le
secteur social nous avons identifié ce
point comme très particulier vous avez
aussi évoqué dans un second sujet qui
suit du virage domiciliaire vieillir
chez soi le plus longtemps possible
c'est ce que souhaite nous concitoyens
c'est ce que nous souhaitons en vérité
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que nous
avons remis à votre commission en
janvier dernier une communication sur
les services de soins à domicile qui
montrent l'utilité la pertinence de ceci
mais il faut aussi prendre en compte les
risques particuliers ou qu'elles sont
exposées les salariés qui interviennent
au domicile des personnes âgées ou
handicapées risquent liés aux transports
risquent lié à l'état du domicile à
personne sur lequel l'employeur n'a pas
de capacité d'agir risque lié au fait
que le salarié intervient seul donc il
faut agir tous ces plans vous deux
dernières questions conçues pour moi un
point de grande attention qui est le
contrôle des EHPAD notamment privé
lucratif c'est un enjeu de premier plan
d'abord pour la qualité et la sécurité
de nos citoyens j'ai aussi pour le bon
usage des fonds publics
nous avons expertisé le projet d'article
32 prévu par le plfc sur le renforcement
de pouvoir des ARS et des conseils
départementaux ça rejoint les analyses
de notre rapport tel que vous l'avons
soumis et celui que vous avez fait
madame ni avec Monsieur bonne
d'excellente qualité très inspirant je
sais en la matière c'est les
dispositions sont indispensables je me
borne à deux remarques la première c'est
de s'assurer que la rédaction proposée
couvre bien tous les montages possibles
tous par lesquels des établissements et
services du secteur médico-social sont
contrôlés par des personnes tierces et
l'expérience montre que le diable est
dans les détails par exemple peut-on
certains que la rédaction couvre bien le
cas ou une superposition de structure
associative et privée commerciale
dispose du contrôle direct ou indirect
la seconde c'est qu'il faut compléter
je le redis merci de me donner
l'occasion le code des juridictions
financières pour garantir à la cour aux
gens régionales de pouvoir contrôler la
totalité des ressources des
établissements gestionnaires et des
groupes auxquels ils appartiennent ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui notamment
dans tout ce qui résulte tarifs
d'hébergement ou les suppléments
pratiqués à l'endroit des usagers les
scandales qui se sont produits qui ont
été révélés montrent à quel point ce
secteur doit être davantage contrôlé et
je redis que l'institution que je
préside les gens régionales des comptes
sont à mon sens à l'évidence les mieux
placés les plus légitimes pour le faire
d'où encore une fois le travail que je
vous propose de faire ensemble pour
parvenir à améliorer l'initiation je
suis persuadé qu'on peut parvenir sur ce
point consensus général entre le
gouvernement d'une part et les deux
assemblées d'autre part ce sera un
progrès en veillant bien sûr à certaines
préoccupations juridiques qui doivent
être prises en compte
avec son acuité habituelle m'a posé
plusieurs questions d'abord sur la
pertinence des soins il y a plusieurs
outils qui existent qui sont à la
disposition de la CNAM mais pouvoir
public mais ils sont sous-utilisés la
rémunération au forfaits des médecins la
régulation prévue qui fonctionne plutôt
bien pour la biologie médicale la
prévention qu'il part en pauvre de la
politique de santé enfin la maîtrise
médicalisée c'est à dire le juste soin
dispensé à bon escient ou plus juste au
coup et là il y a des sources
d'économiques qui comme vous l'avez dit
sont considérables on considérables
évidemment sur la fraude la la courbe va
revenir sur le suivi de ces
recommandations sur la fraude prestation
sociale dans le rapport que vous aviez
demandé à l'époque dans vos fonctions de
rapporteur général de cette commission
dès le Ralph 2023 qui sera produit en
juin
qui vient sur le travail des seniors oui
c'est un sujet central j'ai lu comme
vous une excellente interview de joie
Hervé le lundi ce matin dans un
quotidien bien informé l'auto-emploi des
seniors est encore décalé par rapport
aux autres pays clairement c'est un
enjeu tout à fait essentiel dont on
parle peu dans la réflexion sur la forme
des retraites qui quand même assez
complexe pour les entreprises il faut
pas se le cacher là non plus ça va pas
être la solution magique mais ça doit
pas être pour autant une solution
esquivée monsieur Milon a posé des
questions fondamentales sur la
durabilité de la protection sociale
je vais faire une réponse que tu me
répondes de conviction sans du tout
minimiser vos alertes qui sont comme
toujours pertinentes c'est possible à
une condition qui est d'éviter la
spirale de la dette ce qui n'est
évidemment pas ce que nous constatons
mais non c'est un sujet tout à fait
Vidal que c'est question de la dette qui
est mal posée souvent
on s'interroge juste sur le niveau de la
dette bon il est très élevé il est plus
élevé en France que dans la moyenne de
la zone euro il est plus élevé que dans
la plupart des nos pays compétiteurs en
soi c'est un problème mais il y a pas de
problème de soutenabilité notre dette
elle est finançable puisque la France
est plutôt une bonne signature parce que
nous sommes accrochés à l'Allemagne etc
mais le problème de la dette c'est qu'on
est fait plus elle grossit plus se crée
renforçant du service de la dette et
moins nous avons la capacité à partir de
ce moment-là à déployer des dépenses
utiles et donc chaque euro qui est
consacré au remboursement du service là
je le dis à ceux qui rêvent d'une
augmentation constante de la dette ça
n'a pas de sens la dépense publique doit
s'arrêter à un moment donné parce que
trop de dettes tu la dépense publique
utile on ne pourra pas investir dans la
transition écologique la transition
numérique l'innovation la recherche
d'éducation la justice sociale et la
protection sociale si on a une dette
trop élevée à un moment donné
effectivement ça s'arrête sommes-nous au
point de rupture je peux pas répondre en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut être au
point de l'inflexion et que c'est pour
ça que nous tirons tiens pas la sonnette
d'alarme à pas nous assistons sur le
fait que nous ne sommes pas à la
crédibilité dans les textes qui vous
sont soumis nous sommes pas sur le
système d'assurance maladie et partager
entre assurance maladie et
complémentaire nous partageons votre
avis sur le caractère inefficient de ce
système il y a des évolutions évidentes
qui sont nécessaires nous avons
plusieurs proposés plusieurs scénarios
dans un rapport récent transmis à la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale que vous
connaissez enfin Madame meunier j'ai
rendu hommage à votre rapport que je
crois très utile et tout à fait
complémentaire et d'ailleurs convergent
avec les travaux de la cour en la
matière pour l'extension des compétences
juridictions financières à mon sens il
en faut
une double une extension horizontale
pour pouvoir élargir à la section
hébergement de pouvoir de contrôle et
aussi une extension verticale pour
pouvoir contrôler l'ensemble des plus
financiers entre établissement
gestionnaire et leur maison mère il faut
aussi c'était évoquer ici que nous
puissions faire des des contrôles qui
soient plus inopinés qu'aujourd'hui
forcément un contrôle
averti trop longtemps à l'avance
permettre de découvrir des situations
qui ne sont pas forcément celles qu'on
vit autrement et je le redis ce sera mon
dernier mot nous y tenons nous avons
vraiment envie de nous investir
davantage sur ce secteur nous pensons
que c'est attendu il y a vraiment là une
cause nationale qui est fondamentale et
nous sommes à votre disposition pour
vous communiquer un projet d'abondance
que je suggère c'est peut-être de le
passer madame la Présidente et que pour
le dispatch aux différents groupes et
nous sommes à
disposition de tous les sénateurs pour
travailler sur une bonne rédaction si il
est nécessaire de l'améliorer merci
monsieur le Premier Président donc tout
à fait d'accord en effet pour cet
amendement et puis nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir puisque nous
attendons un rapport sur santé publique
France à la fin de l'année je crois tout
à fait
il est dans les tuyaux c'est parfait
merci beaucoup et à bientôt donc à
bientôt